jake paul right here knocks out tyron
woodley in the sixth round to win the
rematch
um
good
woodley doesn't throw enough punches
you know and the fight is just a lot of
like punch inner you know clutch or you
know
hug
punch hug punch hug
they should lose a point if they hug
or
see who's willing to take it to second
base if you're hugging whoever you know
who's willing to you know
go even further a little you know what
i'm saying no my bro but
you know because y'all fighting and
y'all loving
those boys cuz it's just those fights
it's a lot of just punch hug punch hug a
lot of the um
kind of like uh these trailer fights are
select you know the celeb this whole new
uh
zydeco of fighting this new
realm
it's a lot of punch hugging
and damn woodley got knocked out
god
it was painful and at the same time i'm
just damn jealous
you know i'm like god i just
i'd love to be able to just sleep like
that
the rest the immediate
it takes me so long to get to bed at
night
and the rest he got
i mean it was just immediate
you know no counting sheep no
uh
somebody's sitting there reading you a
book
and you're an adult and you're like why
enough who is this
who's reading to me
um
none of that no
and none of it
just good and hot
good night
hello good night
and so that was just man that's the part
i'm envious it should be a hampton inn
commercial
want to get some rest
bam
try the jake paul suite
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you